[Music]
since 2017 Riverdale has been one of the
most popular binge-watch worthy shows on
Netflix but did you know it all started
with the 1939 comics the characters
didn't really look the same but stay
tuned to see which character had a
drastic makeover don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the cast of Riverdale and their
comic book characters Archie Andrews
let's start with the character that is
arguably one of the most popular
characters in the series and the comic
books
Archie still has his gorgeous red hair
in fact the Archie you see in Riverdale
and the Archie from the comic books are
actually both quite similar we all know
the Riverdale version of Archie as the
boy that loves to just go for it without
ever thinking about any consequences
some people might call him a typical boy
with a certain description in front of
the word boy we're not allowed to repeat
but Archie in the comic books is
slightly more lovable he's shown as the
typical teenager and he first appeared
in the Archie comics in 1941 just like
the Riverdale version this Archie also
wants to impress the girls at any chance
he gets but he is also super clumsy and
relatable which makes him that much more
appealing no offense to the Riverdale
Archie looks-wise they kind of look the
same except for the fact that Archie
definitely wasn't this buff and athletic
guests eating all that protein and
sticking to your macronutrients really
does pay off right and in case you're
wondering the love triangle is still
there in the comics Betty Cooper ah
where do we even start with Betty she's
definitely the smartest of the
mysterious little town and knows what's
up when something's up Betty has had
plenty of good moments on the show but
if you love her character you should
definitely read the comics
she's also super relatable and she still
has a crush on Archie in the comics
Betty is more into sports than just
cheerleading but she's also a scuba
diver and she's really into making her
own clothing just like her TV version
the comic version of Betty has an above
average intelligence and she's one of
the smartest students at Riverdale take
that blonde stereotypes looks-wise
Betty's character is still blond in the
comics her eyes are sometimes described
as blue
sometimes as Brown which is perfect
because the TV Betty Cooper's eyes are a
mix of every color but the main
difference is in her emotional state
we know the TV version of Betty comes
with a lot of childhood baggage but that
baggage isn't there in the comics in
fact she's extremely loving and always
willing to help everyone at all times
and in case you want to know the rivalry
between Betty and Veronica is still
there Veronica Lodge and here she is the
one you love to hate there's no one
quite like Veronica Lodge but in the TV
show Veronica's hair is black and in the
comics her hair is brown she also has
medium length hair complete with bangs
which is something we never see on the
TV version but this Veronica is just as
spoiled and she's always concerned about
her appearance crazy about shopping and
designer clothes she's known to max out
her father's credit cards the TV version
of Veronica does have a lot of fashion
sense but it seems that only the comic
book version uses that passion she's
extremely knowledgeable on clothing and
she also frequently models it's also
revealed that the comic book version of
Veronica is good at math and economics
which is something that's never revealed
on the show well except for the time
when she helped Chuck with his math
problem over the phone the comic book
version also named Veronica as one of
the prettiest girls in town and at some
point she even ranked as number 87 in
the comics buyer's guide 100 sexiest
women in comics list someone needs to do
the popular karma challenge and do a
comic book version of Veronica versus
the TV version Jughead Downes alright
it's time to talk about the one and only
Jughead Jones in the show Jughead has
black hair and blue eyes but in the
comics he has black hair and black eyes
in the comics jugheads intelligence punk
stantly changes depending on the story
he sometimes known as a bit slow but
he's also shown to be really smart in
the show
Jughead is most known for his writing
skills that allow him to tell the tale
of the Riverdale tone but those writing
skills don't exist in the comics the
comic version of Jughead also shows him
as an always hungry dude whose brain
actually can't survive unless she's
constantly munching on food the comic
version of Jughead also had a dog called
hot dog
who
appears in the 13th episode of Riverdale
but the biggest change of them all is
the fact that jug had an Archie were
actually best friends in the comics
which only makes you think about the
stereotypical status quo the TV show had
to make we kind of wish the TV show
would keep them as friends though
because we have a feeling the true story
would take a completely different turn
in one of the comic books Jughead also
becomes completely obsessed with the
skateboarding culture Reggie mantle and
then there's Reggie he's a bit of a hit
and miss with the Riverdale's fandom
because let's be honest he doesn't
really bring much to the table apart
from being the typical jock on the show
he's best known for selling the jingle
jangle to high schoolers if you know
what we mean but in the comic books
Reggie's a slightly different character
well apart from his looks because he
actually looks almost the same as his
comic with Persian the comic book
version is still very much into sports
but he's also a real Casanova and always
seems to date other women he's not only
a jock but a pre well-rounded athlete
and he even does kung-fu while Reggie
might not be a beloved character in the
series he seems to be very much beloved
in the comics
well at least beloved by himself you see
Reggie has a nickname called Reggie I
love me mantle and you can commonly see
him with a comb looking at himself in
the mirror typical jock stuff isn't it
he's also a seasonal prankster although
his pranks always seemed to backfire the
comic book version of Reggie's also
Archie's arch-nemesis so he definitely
brings more to the table Sharyl blossom
first of all Cheryl blossom sounds like
she could be in the Powerpuff Girls if
there was an evil and manipulative
Powerpuff Girl out there the comic
version of Cheryl looks fairly similar
except to the fact that Cheryl's eyes
and the Archie comics are green not
brown the Cheryl in the comics is much
more manipulative but she also seems to
have a caring side depending on the
story and unlike Riverdale Cheryl she's
not a cheer captain in fact there's no
mention of her being involved in any
after-school activities well apart from
the whole Archie thing if that counts
her character is actually so similar the
original story also implies there was
something going on between her and her
rather the implications were subtle but
obvious enough to make Cheryl's
character disappear from the comics for
a while because it was just too much for
the readers but there's one thing the
Riverdale version of Cheryl has that
this one doesn't it's a relationship
with Heather that was just briefly
mentioned in the show but gains quite a
lot of attention of course that's
totally expected considering the times
but it would have been an interesting
backstory to Cheryl's Riverdale
character Keven Keller seriously who
doesn't love Kevin well if you love his
dark hair it might surprise you because
he has a blonde hair in the comics he
also has light green eyes on the show
and blue eyes in the comics the comic
version of Kevin is also much more
muscular and built as if he'd been
heavily into sports although that's
never the highlight of his story it's
also revealed that Veronica has a thing
for Kevin but he's totally uninterested
and get this it's also revealed that
he's gay in the comics yep kevin was the
first openly gay character in the Archie
comics for that reason his character
wasn't introduced until 2010 in the 2012
comic titled life with Archie Kevin also
gets married and we don't want to break
your heart but you should probably know
that he doesn't end up with Mason it
seems that his future is just as bright
in the comics as it is on the actual
show
Kevin's a beloved and revolutionary
character and the fans of both the
comics and the show who want to see more
characters like him after all we all
love characters we can actually relate
with so it makes sense right
josie and the pussycats and who can
forget the Pussycats that have to claw
their way into a room people can just
normally walk in - of course Josie and
the Pussycats were slightly more
developed in the Archie comics than they
were in Riverdale so much so that they
had their own storyline that later got
transformed into a Sunday morning
cartoon and while melody and Valerie
don't really do much on Riverdale
Melanie was the one that co-founded the
group in the comics but what's different
about the TV version of the girls is the
fact that Josie is the one that's black
while melody is black in the comics in
fact melody was the first black
reoccurring character in an American
cartoon the comics also rebooted the
band in 2016
Josie's also the character that's the
most different in the comics she's much
nicer and kinder
just about everyone she meets for some
reason the girls have very mysterious
last names in the comic book version
with Valerie being the only one we know
but overall the girls still look the
same in the comics as they do on the TV
screen and yep the iconic cat ears are
still there
moose Mason moose is a typical job
probably even more typical than Archie
in the comics he's the one that's
usually dim-witted a completely
good-hearted he's kind to everyone as
long as people don't mess with his
girlfriend yep that's right
in the comics moose his girlfriend Mitch
it's the highlight of his story and the
two are very happy together
moose is also blonde in the comics and
his muscles are out of this world
seriously the TV version of moose can't
even compare moose on-screen is also
much more of a complex and dark
character while the comic book version
would never hurt a fly with the main
difference between the two characters is
the fact that the comic book version of
the moose isn't secretly gay at all
these interactions with Kevin aren't
even present in the comics moose is slow
demeanor was later also revealed to be
dyslexia which is something the show
never mentions in fact now that we think
about it mooses intelligence isn't a big
focus on the show at all and although
his TV version is much more complex and
slightly dark we do prefer his TV
complexity over his simple and straight
to-the-point character in the comic
books miss Grundy so let's talk about
one of arguably the worst characters
this show has ever had at least that's
what people say whenever they rank for
Verdell characters miss Grundy doesn't
really have a good rep but why should
she considering she had an affair with
an underage student well that pot line
doesn't really exist in the comics but
that's because miss Grundy is really old
like white hair old and because she's a
much better person on her TV counterpart
the comics show her as a grumpy old
teacher that doesn't like her students
being late she takes no nonsense and she
absolutely doesn't think Archie is
worthy of her attention and any other
way other than school stuff way to go
miss Grundy in the comics miss Grundy
also gets married to the Riverdale high
school principal and overall she sounds
like a much better person well apart
from the fact that she's this strict
teacher no student would really like in
real life but hey that's normal
if the two versions of miss Grundy are
so different does that really count as
the same character she was practically
reinvented on the show but it looks like
the team lost the plot with this one and
that's all for our video who's your
favorite Riverdale character let us know
in the comments thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]